what the [ __ ] is this
[Music]
just because i am in the comfort of my
own home doesn't mean that i can't save
uh fix your lives did i say save your
lives i can't do that
i meant fix your lives that i can do
fixed it fixed it fixed it fixed it
fixed it fixed
it fixed it you're welcome you're
welcome
you're welcome you're welcome you're
welcome you're welcome you're welcome
you're welcome
you're welcome you're welcome oh my god
how many more questions
are there jesus christ there's so many
questions
let's get started benavidez
4182 said what's some things you can do
when
bored at home oh watch tv just watch tv
i just watch tv you don't like watching
tv
you know it's always fun you know what i
like to do but i don't do it enough
but if when i do it it sucks up my whole
day is i like to make
movies with footage so they like to
shoot stuff
and then i put it into like an app like
imovie or
a really easy editing thing and i
make like a little movie and it takes up
so much time
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
maybe it's okay to be bored sometimes
linsbrenner cimino or chimino said
pregnant due in may what should my first
alcoholic drink be
it's
[Laughter]
oh i like you i don't know you but we'd
be friends
um what should my first alcoholic drink
bee
oh god you gotta go hard don't even mess
with wine or prosecco or anything
or like beer don't even bother go
straight for the hard stuff
because when i
when i go for a really long time without
drinking and then suddenly drink again
all i want to do is just like get
real drunk let's take some shots
together
fixed it olive stirs says how to
how do you keep your relationship
romantic during quarantine times
oh that's
how do you keep it romantic i feel like
being stuck in a house with someone is
just
by default romantic am i wrong i might
be wrong in this i think a lot of people
probably heard me say that and be like
uh what are you talking about like
obviously
i stopped trying with my appearance
um you know i stopped wearing makeup a
long time ago
i put way too much product in my hair
now i don't think i remember the last
time i put my contact lenses in
so um but
i don't know i think but also my husband
and i are like
still pretty fresh we're like a year and
a half
we're pretty fresh you gotta read a
cosmo
uh i'm sure they have like
cool tips and stuff um
i'm i don't know i'm thinking like i
don't know make a mistake
make your significant other mistake i
don't know
you know role play watch porn together
i don't know do that stuff that's not
really romantic but
you know it could be
it could be depends on the porn you
watch
i gotta i gotta stop you're welcome
alicia demps said why won't my boyfriend
close cabinets after he opens them
i don't know why doesn't he what is he
doing why would you leave it open why
are we leaving it open
i have no idea you know what i do that
sometimes um and i'm not proud of myself
why won't he that's the question isn't
why won't he
it's can he change his behavior and i
think he can and i think he knows he can
you just can't nag him don't close him
don't close the cabinet if he leaves him
open don't close him
and then he'll come down and be like why
are all the cabinets open
and then he'll realize that he's part of
the problem
i don't know if that'll work but
why wouldn't he close cap you know what
he's got he's got to just change his
behavior
what's what's your boyfriend's name
listen alicia dumps his boyfriend
close the cabinets what are we doing why
would you leave him open
come on get your [ __ ] together
you're welcome oh boy i says
how can i learn to say no to people
without feeling guilty or having to
explain myself
oh my god that was my problem for a long
time
how do i say no to people and i didn't
i'd say yes to everyone
and then i would double triple book
myself i mean i have friends
and people would get really pissed off
at me i'd always be late or i'd flake
and it was awful
and then i just really made a a mental
note to just like make
put plans in my calendar and then when
people ask me to do things i'd say like
uh no i can't make it because i had
something in there but that's how you're
asking
how do you say no to people without
feeling guilty i realized
that when you say no one time the first
time
it's much easier to say no after that
so i know for me it was really hard to
say no the first time whenever someone
asked because i say yes
to everything all the time and so
when they asked if i could like do
something i was like i think
i don't think i can and they were like
okay because you think their whole
response is gonna be like
oh cool so we're just not friends
anymore and then when you realize that's
not their response it makes you
it makes it much easier to say no you
know what put yourself first
that's what oprah used to say i think
that's what she said
i can't remember it sounds like
something she would say
be like oprah john boo yeesi
says my wife wants to lose weight and
gets mad that i want to keep eating
cookies what do i do
so she wants to lose weight she doesn't
want you eating cookies
eat them in secret if she can't have
cookies
obviously she doesn't want to watch you
eating cookies so just
cower somewhere in the corner of your
living
arrangement and eat a cookie or in the
middle of the night
come down and eat cookies i listen
my husband is very health conscious
and i need chocolate on a regular basis
and sometimes i feel guilty because i'm
like should i
not want to eat this all the time should
i try to be more health conscious
and then i realized you know what
chocolate makes me happy
and if he doesn't want me to be happy
that's his problem no i mean i guess i
don't know if it sounds like she just
wants
you to be healthy but you can be healthy
and eat a cookie
or five
like i'm not a nutritionist but i think
you can do that
so find a study that says chocolate's
good for you and give it to her
and just let's tell her like or maybe
make
healthy cookies like instead of sugar
you're using
i don't know honey
or like maple syrup
or i don't know some other healthier
sugar
coconut sugar is that healthier i don't
know maybe make an alternative cookie
that's just
not as unhealthy you guys can both eat
it together
good luck to your wife um and i think
it's very sweet that you
don't want to flaunt the cookies in
front of her
that's good fixed it fixed your life
and your marriage you're welcome ae phil
says
just broke up with my toxic friend group
and now i have no friends
what now well done
well done that is tough toxic friends
suck ass um
toxic friends suck i shouldn't say suck
ass
because that's a little harsh uh you
just have to make new friends i know
it's like
a little jarring to make new friends
but you seem really nice and you seem
like you know what you want
which is good so you really just have to
go out there and
it is hard to make friends after a
certain age i mean in elementary school
you're like
standing by the pencil sharpener with
some kid and you're like do you want to
be best friends forever and they're like
yeah
so you can't do that as an adult
i wish there was a tinder for friendship
that would be really fun
maybe you need to invent an app tinder
for friendship
if there's no like romance involved it's
just
do you want to go to the movies and just
hang out platonic lee
with me um but i think you're gonna be
fine
i think you know what it's better that
you don't have
any friends than have friends who are
all toxic
because toxic friends can
ruin your life all right
good luck i think you're going to be
fine i'll be your friend
fixed it it's done
i did it it did them all
i did them all all right
that's it